يحمل معه دلاله سياسيه مهمه
على تطوير علاقتنا والتصدي للتحديات
المشتركه
التي تواجه اوطاننا
ولعل العقاد قيمتنا العربيه هو في حد ذاته
دعوه دعوه لاستلام روح القوميه العربيه
والدفاع عن حقوق شعوبنا وصول المقدراتها
وما احوجنا اليوم
الى التذكار محطات التعاون المضيئه في
تاريخنا
التي
تجسدت فيها اسماء معاني العروبه والاخاء
والتكاتف لرفع الرايات الحق والعقل
وبما يعيد الحقوق لاصحابها ويحفظ
الاستقرار ومستقبل ومستقبل الاجيال
القادمه
وان تاريخ امتنا العربيه
من احداث في الماضي القريب
يثبت لنا جميعا وبما لا يدعي مجالا للشك
ان ما قد يؤلم اشقائنا بالمغرب العربي
[موسيقى]
ان امننا القومي العربي هو كل لا يتجزا
بين
الاخطار التي تدعم دولنا واحده
وترتبط في مجملها بتهديد مفهوم الدوله
الوطنيه
اجنبيه في شؤون المنطقه من خلال تغذيه
النزاعات وصولا الى الاعتداء العسكري
المباشر على بعض الدول العربيه
وكلها عوامل افضل الى طول امد الازمات دون
حل في زمن تشتد فيه التحديات الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه والبيئيه عالميا واقليميا
ويزيد في الاستقطاب الدولي الذي اصبح عنصر
ضاغطا سياسيا واقتصاديا على نحو بات يؤثر
علينا جميعا
لقد اثارت هذه التحديات
العديد من الشواغر المشروعه لدى الشارع
العربي الذي بات يتساءل عن الاسباب التي
تعيد تحقيق التكامل بين دول الاقليم
العربي في مختلف المجالات
الذباب التي تحول دون ان تلحق امتنا ذات
الموارد والامكانات الهائله بركب الامم
الاكثر تقدم
بل صار يتساءلون عن غياب التصور
والاجراءات المطلوبه اتخاذها لوقف نزيف
الدم العربي ورده تدخلات القوى الخارجيه
والحد من اهدار ثروات المنطقه في غير
مقاصدها الصحيحه
للصراعات التي لن تحل بمعادله صفريه يقصى
فيها طرف او يجار على حقوقه
ومن الواقع الترابط الفعلي الذي يجعلنا
جميعا اعضاء لجسد الواحد ومن واقع حجم
التحديات والضغوط الراهنه الذي يفوق قدره
اي دوله على التصدي لها منفرده فانه يتعين
علينا تبني مقاربه مشتركه وشامله تهدف الى
تعزيز قدرتنا الجماعيه على مواجهه مختلف
الازمات
استنادا على اساس واضحه تقوم على تكريس
مفهوم الوطن العربي الجامع من ناحيه
والدوله الوطنيه ودعم دور مؤسساتها
الدستوريه من ناحيه اخرى
بما يسهل في حفظ السلم الاجتماعي
رقائز الحكم الرشيد والمواطنه وحقوق
الانسان ونبذ الطائفيه والتعصب والقضاء
على التنظيمات الارهابيه والمنشيات
المسلحه وقتل الطريق امام اي محاولات
لدعمهم او منحهم غطاء سياسيا او توظيفهم
من قبل بعض القوى سواء الاقليميه او
الدوليه لانشاء مناطق نفوز لها في العالم
العربي
وان ضمان قوه وحده صف العربي هي خطه
اساسيه على صعيد تاسيس علاقات جوار اقليمي
مستقيمه تستند الى مبادئ غير قابله
للمساومه وملزمه للجميع
احترام استقلال وسياده وعروبه دولنا
وتحقيق المنفعه المتبادله وحسن الجوار
والاجتماع الكامل عن التدخل في الشؤون
العربيه
في تحقيق شراكه فعليه فيما بين دولنا على
ارضيه ما يجمعنا من تاريخ المشترك والتطلع
نحو مستقبل اكثر ازدهارا يتشكل من خلال
اطلاع كل دول كل دوله بمسؤوليتها على
النطاق الوطنيه
في سياق الاوسع من العمل الجماعي على
تعزيز قدراتنا العربيه سياسيا واقتصاديا
وامنيا
فتكامل القدرات المتباينه
المتباينه انما ينشئ منظومه صلبه قادره
على مواجهه التحديات المشتركه والازمات
الدوليه المستجده بما في ذلك ازمه الطاقه
والغذاء بل انها ستوفر الحمايه الرئيسيه
لنا جميعا من الاستقطاب الدولي الاخذ في
التصاعد في الفتره الاخيره هذا الاستقطاب
الذي بات له تبعات سلبيه على التناول
الدولي لازمات منطقتنا العربيه
واعادل الاذهان مظاهر عقبه تاريخيه عانى
في العالم باسره
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم ان المضي
قدما على طريق اللحاق بركبه تقدم والتنميه
يتطلب العمل الجاد على تسويه مختلف ازمات
عالمنا العربيه وعلى راسها دوما وابدا
القضيه الفلسطينيه وارد هنا الاشاره الى
ان قدرتنا على العمل الجماعي لتسويه
لتسويه القضيه واسترجاع الحقوق الفلسطينيه
كانت تاريخيا وستظل المعايير الحقيقي لمدى
تماسكنا
كما تظل المبادره العربيه للسلام تكسيدا
لهذا التماسك ولرؤيتنا المشتركه اداء الحل
العادل والشامل على اساس حل دولتين مبدا
الارض مقابل السلام وبما يقفل انشاء دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله على حدود الرابع من يونيو
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
تعيد للفلسطينيين وطنهم وتسمح بعوده
اللاجئين بما يتفق مع مبادئ القانون
الدولي والشرعيه الدوليه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
مازلنا نحتاج المزيد من العمل العربي
الجامعي حتى في التعامل مع الازمات
الجديده التي جاءت لاحقا على القضيه
الفلسطينيه في ليبيا وسوريا واليمن
والعراق والسودان
والا سيظل امن والسلم الشعوب الشقيقه في
تلك الدول مهددين بتجدد واياد تلك الازمات
وستظل الاخيره ثغرات في المنظومه العربيه
ومراكز لعدم الاستقرار وهو ما يؤثر علينا
جميعا ويعلق الجهودنا في التنميه والتكامل
ولعله من الملائم ان اشارككم هنا رغبتنا
في دعمكم لمساعنا الحاليه في ليبيا
الشقيقه للتوصل في اسرع وقت الى تسويه
سياسيه بقياده وملكيه ليبيه خالصه دون
املاءات خارجيه اصولا الى اجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه بالتزامن واحترام مؤسسات
الدوله
وصلاحياتها بمقدار الاتفاقات المبرمه
وتنفيذ خروج جميع القوات الاجنبيه
والمرتزقه والمقاتلين الاجانب في مدى زمني
محدد واعاده توحيد مؤسسه الدوله الليبيه
وحلل من الشات بما يحول دون تجدد
المواجهات العسكريه ويعيد البلاد وحداتها
وسيادتها واستراليا
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو قبل ان
اختتم كلمته وفي نفس السياق وحده الامن
القومي العربي اود ان وجه هدايتكم الى
معضله الامن المائي التي تؤثر على عدد من
الدول العربيه وتنزل بعواقب وقيمه اذا تم
تجاهلها وفي هذا السياق نجدد تاكيد على
اهميه الاستمرار في حث اثيوبيا على التحلي
بالاراده السياسيه وحسن النوايا اللازمين
للتوسل اتفاق قانون ملزم بشان سد النهضه
الاثيوبيه
التنفيذيان البيان الرئاسي الصادر عن مجلس
الامن في سبتمبر 2021
والاخذ باي من الحلول الكثيره التي طرحت
عبر العديد من جوالات المفاوضات التي تؤمن
مصالح الشعب الاثيوبي الاقتصاديه الان
ومستقبلا وتصوم في الوقت ذاته حياه
الشعبين المصري والسوداني
ولا ينفصل تحدي الامن المائي عن تحديات
اخرى تواجهها المنطقه وفي مقدمتها تغير
المناخ الذي اصبح واقعا مفروضا على العالم
هذه المناسبه للاعرابي عن تطلع
الاستقبالكم في مصر يوم ايه سبعه وثمانيه
نوفمبر 2022 بقمه شرم الشيخ لتنفيذ
تعاهدات المناخ لتحويل هذا التحدي الى
فرصه حقيقيه للتنميه والانتقال الى انماطم
الاقتصاديه اكثر استدامه لصالحنا جميعا
الاشقاء الاعزاء ان تسويه الازمات العربيه
والتعاطي مع التحديات الدوليه ينطلق اساسا
من ايماننا بوحده اهدافنا ومصرنا وتفعيل
لتعاوننا وامكانياتنا وادواتنا في مسائل
الامن الجماعيه وذلك بالتوازي مع جهودنا
في التكامل على المسارات الاخرى والمنظر
حولنا لقد سبقتنا تكتلات الاخرى نحو
التكامل رغم ان من اطرافها من عنه من تنحر
الحقيقي بل هو حروب فيما بينهم فما بالكم
بنا ونحن لدينا من المشتركات في الثقافه
والاديان والتاريخ والوجه السياسيه ويحتم
علينا
وتجاوز اختلافات وجهات نظرينا
ختاما اتوجه برساله الى شعبنا فاقول
ثقوب في امتنا العربيه فهي صاحب التاريخ
حريق وسام حضري ثري وممتد وما زالت تلك
الامه تمتلك المقاومات اللازمه لمستقبل
اكثر استقرار المظاهر وعلى راسها عزيمتكم
وعقولكم وسواعدكم وثقوا فان مصر ستضع دوما
نصب عيونها تماسك الكاهن العربي وصونه
وحمايته وستظل دائما حاضره دعما لكم
وستبقي على ابوابها مفتوحه امام كل ابناء
العرب في سبيل الدفاع عن حاضرهم ومستقبل
الاديان القادمه شكرا والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
شكرا فخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي